it is intimidating and we do everything
to try and make it less intimidating and
for that reason we've started something
called saturdays at philips where we
sell less expensive items but not of
lesser quality and these are usually
priced between five hundred dollars and
twenty thousand dollars we do those
sales on the Saturday as the name says
we offer bagels cappuccinos there's pop
music and so just to make it a very
relaxed experience and then we see that
most of the clients who come to these
sales of a young and have never bought
at auction before one thing is sure the
first time they've bought they
definitely will come back I mean the
second search step follows automatically
and there is no reason to be intimidated
because these or exhibitions are open to
everyone whether you're going to buy or
not whether we have money to spend or
not it's totally irrelevant these are
great opportunities to see greater